Marvel has a lot of villains in its
Cinematic Universe but which one stand
above the rest when it comes to menacing
Earth's Mightiest Heroes to answer that
increasingly complicated question we've
watched every MCU movie and ranked all
of their many bad guys from bad rock and
Surtur to whiplash and Thanos and
everyone in between this list only
focuses on tried and true villains so
you won't find reformed heroes like
Scarlet Witch Quicksilver nebula or the
Winter Soldier we're talking 100%
baddies through and through so where
does your favorite villain right here's
our spoiler filled take on every MCU
villain ranked from worst to best curse
in the dark world curse leads a prison
riot helps malakut sack Asgard and
actually kills Thor's motherfreakin he
also leads the battle against Thor in
the film's climax beating the Thunder
gods senseless with his brute strength
despite all that curse is still little
more than a forgettable monster with no
personality he's the ultimate mini boss
and is in the basement on this lists
rankings laughy Blau fee is a powerful
force in Thor's corner of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but we never really
see much of him in action the king of
the frost giants and biological father -
Loki he has super strength and ice
powers but he's still no match for the
sneakiness of his own son Loki
manipulates events to get Lao fleet to
attack ice garden Thor
but just as la fée is about to kill Odin
Loki takes out laughy instead
simultaneously killing the frost giant
King and making himself look like a hero
certainly an unceremonious end brant and
Sabbath aldrich killian
turned out to be an a-list bad guy in
Iron Man 3 with Branton Savin shaping up
as little more than b-list versions with
the same powers both are given their
super heating and healing powers by the
extremis virus and they both attack Tony
Stark throughout the film but neither is
a match for Iron Man even when he
doesn't have a suit blame the scorpion
he's a pretty big deal in the comics but
it's spider-man homecoming not so much
the scorpions most notable actions are
complete failures first when an arms
deal is interrupted by spider-man and
then later when he tries to get the
sinister six going in prison before
being shut down by the vulture basically
he's just there to make Adrian Toomes
look cooler by comparison when you're
not as cool as the vulture it's safe to
say you screwed up pretty bad somewhere
along the way Batroc the leaper it's
easy to forget but yes Batroc the leaper
is part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
we met the French mercenary during the
action sequence that opens the Winter
Soldier during the hijacking of the ship
the Lemurian star we get a breathless
fight scene between the two with cap
accepting bat Rock's challenge for a
hand-to-hand fight without a shield
Batroc holds his own though cab
eventually knocks him out but hey at
least he's a little cooler than this
version the Shockers spider-man
homecoming gave us not just one but two
shockers we first meet Jackson Bryce
wielding a shocker gauntlet but then
after the vulture kills him the weapons
passed on to Herman Schultz Schultz
looks to be our main shocker in the MCU
and he gets one epic fight against
Spidey before being sidelined shocker
jumps Peter as he leaves the school
dance attempting to follow the vulture
and sends him flying through a school
bus and he loses his web-shooters too so
white a shocker ranked solo because it
wasn't even Spidey who took him out it
was Pete Powell Ned who grabs the
web-shooter and hits shocker distracting
him long enough for Spidey to web him to
a school bus shocking Baron von Strucker
Strucker led the experiments on Loki's
scepter that created Quicksilver in The
Scarlet Witch so he's definitely
important but all anyone really
remembers about him is his immediate
surrender to the Avengers during the
opening of age of Ultron
I'm going to surrender in the end
Strucker was just another upper level
high Dragoon cut off his head and no one
really noticed the destroyer when the
destroyer shows up in Thor it makes full
use of every moment the Destroyers giant
powerful arms and legs can crush or stop
just about any opponent and if they
don't kill you its laser blasts probably
will
we saw the destroyer kill a few frost
giants then lay waste to a small town in
New Mexico when Loki sent it to earth
hunting Thor still it was no match for
Thor when the god of thunder regained
his power and overcharged the destroyer
ending the attack Justin Hammer credits
Sam Rockwell's unending charisma for
Iron Man two's Dustin hammer not showing
up at the very bottom of this list or
even further down if we could find a way
to put him there as far as credible
villains are concerned Justin Hammer is
an absolute joke he runs an arms
manufacturer that's a rival to Stark
Industries except literally everything
hammer builds falls apart the first
version of the war machine armor is
basically a bare-bones Iron Man suit
outfitted with a ton of hammer weapons
which work about as well as duct-taping
accessories to a car to summarize Sam
Rockwell is great Justin Hammer still
kind of sucks though general Ross in the
Incredible Hulk general Thaddeus
Thunderbolt Ross spends the entire film
chasing Banner failing to kill him a few
times along the way for much of the film
he's a relatively one-dimensional
military bad guy interestingly however
Ross is one of the few characters from
The Incredible Hulk to resurface later
in the MCU he became the US Secretary of
State and Captain America Civil War
pushing for the adoption of the sokovia
accords and even made a cameo in
Avengers infinity war setting him up for
even badder bad guy stuff in films to
come abomination in an effort to capture
the hulk after banners alter ego punches
him through a tree former soldier Emil
Blonsky hits himself with an
experimental version of the same gamma
MacGuffin except it doesn't turn him
into another
instead he becomes the abomination a
monstrous OneNote creature that looks
like a rotting troll yawn he lived
through the end of the Incredible Hulk
and is apparently in a jail cell
somewhere and the fact that Marvel
hasn't really brought him back sense
tells you everything you need to know
Milica dark elf
Malekith had virtually no personality
and basically existed as a freaky
looking dude trying to get an infinity
stone and Thanos already does that way
way better it's a shame because on the
surface Malekith is extremely formidable
the even stage is a surprise assault on
us guard itself reaching the city's
defenses and later sets his sights on
earth he even put up a heck of a fight
against Thor in the final act of the
dark world though the god of thunder
still prevails taser face as rocket
points out more than a few times
taser faces name is pretty dumb but he
still has enough wits to lead a mutiny
among yondu's crew of Ravagers he's big
mean ruthless and conniving and brokers
an uneasy alliance with nebula to take
yondu ship and guardians of galaxy vol 2
he isn't all that bright but hey those
other four traits go a long way for a
while anyway whiplash Mickey Rourke's
whiplash was one of the many problems in
Iron Man 2
despite some admittedly awesome action
scenes along the way whiplash never
feels all that intimidating at least
after that epic attack at the Monaco
Grand Prix he's motivated by a vague
kind of boring backstory and teams up
with Justin Hammer who we've already
established kind of sucks and then
there's that odd obsession with his bird
Raza when Obadiah Stane decides to take
out Tony Stark while Starks on an
overseas tour in the first Iron Man film
he contacts the terrorist organization
the ten rings
led by Raza to make it happen Raza keeps
stark captive and proves an intimidating
villain at least until stark builds his
first version of the Iron Man suit and
makes short work of Roz's soldier
razza was savvy enough to survive and he
tracked down stray bits of Starks armor
and tried to cut another deal with stain
the problem stain was more savvy than
rasa and used a sonic taser to paralyze
him and kill his men despite his
unceremonious ending rasa is still
technically the first villain we meet in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and a
throwback to the simple days of the MCU
poor earth the pursuer
Korath has a small but memorable role in
guardians of the galaxy which provided
one of the most memorable moments from
the movies opening scenes another name
you might know me by star-lord who
star-lord
though star-lord gets the better of him
in the end Korath still puts up a heck
of a fight he also manages to reacquire
the Infinity stone along with nebula
which sets up Ronan the accusers near
world-ending attack on Xander without
Koroth Ronan would never have had the
Infinity stone to begin with so he
certainly served a purpose he even holds
his own against Drax the destroyer for a
while at least until Drax rips out the
cybernetic implant in his head killing
him hey at least he went out fighting
ulysses klaw Andy Serkis actually does
an extremely entertaining job with
Ulysses Klaw in both age of Ultron as
well as Black Panther which gives us a
believable version of the Klaw we know
from the comics a character who still
has the potential to come back after his
death as a dude made of hot pink sound
waves
hopefully the MCU will resurrect this
classic comics be Lister for future
super villainous action sunny birch
Walton Goggins is a genuine delight
every time he shows up on screen and his
appearance in ant-man and the wasp is no
exception
sure he doesn't do much compared to the
likes of kill monger or Thanos but he
might be one of the MCU s most comic
book II villains ever as a dealer in
illicit technology sunny birch is a
character that like the vulture before
him operates on the fringes of a
universe filled with magic hammers and
alien technology the difference is birch
is the kind of sleazy mastermind who
rolls around in a white and gold SUV and
is illegal business in broad daylight
and commands an army of nameless
motorcycle-riding henchmen
he's like a 1960s Batman villain
transplanted directly into the MCU birch
is the perfect character to have around
to reinforce the idea that there's more
to this world than Shakespearean gods
and magic space rocks the tinkerer the
tinkerer is exactly the kind of
character that the MCU needed for the
same reason he was exactly the kind of
character the comics needed someone who
builds all the gadgets the bad guys use
to fight the good guys he's certainly
not the focus of Spider Man homecoming
but Phineas Mason is the kind of bad guy
who makes the MCU feel just a bit more
real the Prowler of all the impressive
things about Spider Man homecoming one
of the most notable is just how many
characters the film pulled in from the
comics and the best minor villain
appearance by far is absolutely aaron
davis known in the comics is the prowler
in the film he's played by Donald Glover
who acts as the thoroughly unimpressed
straight man the Peter Parker's enhanced
interrogation well I would know your
voice I heard you got a bridge I know
what a girl sound like it's one of the
best comedic scenes in the entire MCU
but what makes it really special as
Davis's mention of his nephew as comics
readers know Davis's nephew is Miles
Morales who eventually takes the name of
spider-man as far as villainy goes Davis
doesn't accomplish much beyond a failed
arms deal hinting at a future of the MCU
that includes miles though that's
awesome
Aisha she might not have been the big
bad and guardians of the galaxy vol 2
but the golden goddess Aisha was able to
cause more than enough trouble for
star-lord and his team the leader of the
powerful sovereign she commands a fleet
of remote-controlled warships that come
within one shot of taking out the Milano
following an extensive chase moreover
the post-credits scene revealed aisha
seems to be responsible for creating
Adam warlock a major player in Marvel's
cosmic universe and someone we expect to
meet in guardians of the galaxy vol 3 if
nothing else that makes her more than
worthy of a slot on this list the
Chitauri these invading creeps basically
served as cannon fodder against Earth's
Mightiest Heroes in the final hour of
the Avengers even still they are a
massive alien army led by those
positively terrifying gigantic dragon
like ships that tore through Manhattan
their eventual humiliation
notwithstanding the Chitauri were more
than formidable enough to push the
Avengers to the brink in their first big
screen team-up Arnim Zola in Captain
America the First Avenger arnim zola's
appearance is basically just an easter
egg in Winter Soldier however the setup
of having Zola around for the first
movie pays off in a cool way he might
not be a robot with a camera for a head
and his face on a giant TV screen built
into his tummy like in the comics but
what winter soldiers big reveal lacks in
robot bodies it more than makes up for
by making him genuinely creepy the black
order the black order are perfectly
serviceable henchmen for infinity war
they managed to hit that sweet spot of
being threatening enough to present the
heroes with the challenge but they also
provide additional room for the action
so it's not just 40 people trying to
punch Thanos at the same time ultimately
they're not so threatening that they
overshadow the actual villain of the
piece each of them is distinct and
visually menacing especially ebony maw
unfortunately most of them don't
actually get to do much other than lose
so that's a bit of a drawback Ronan the
accuser in guardians of the galaxy Ronan
was a religious zealot who co-opted the
Power Stone to continue his crusade to
wipe out sand our but even without one
of those awesomely powerful baubles he's
still a heck of a warrior
after all he laid waste to Drax the
destroyer without even breaking a sweat
he also had the guts to stick it to
Thanos and actually walked away from the
mad Titan without much consequence the
guardians were no match for Ronan
individually but luckily star-lord was
able to actually control the Infinity
stone with the help of his team his half
celestial powers and those sweet dance
moves and they used its immense power to
blast a bad guy into oblivion
yellowjacket ant-man's Darren cross
spent his entire career trying to
duplicate Hank Pimm's shrinking formula
but when he did it and created the
Yellow Jacket combat suit he didn't
realize this copycat formula was
actually messing with his brain
chemistry making him dangerously
unstable that led to a villain who is
not only dangerously unhinged but got
some really cool fight scenes the best
of which was on a child's play table
ghost and man in the wasps super-powered
villain has a lot going for him visually
her flickering and phasing through
objects is some of the coolest looking
stuff we've seen in the MCU it's even
better in the fight scenes the shrinking
and growing stuff is fun but hitting
that stuff against a completely
different set of powers makes for some
pretty compelling action since she
seemingly reforms at the end of the film
were obviously meant to like her she has
a sympathetic backstory and motivation
as a victim of Hank Pym Zika testicle
past at the same time we're also
supposed to like Hank
so his party ghosts backstory still
involves him ultimately being right none
of this is too surprising Marvel is full
of bad guys doing the wrong thing for
the right reasons and vice-versa but it
does feel pretty clear the ghost was
shoehorned into ant-man in the wasp
rather than building her more
organically still the effects are great
and hannah john commons performance
captures Ava's understandable bitterness
and desperation effectively Surtur
diehard comics fans know searcher is a
major villain in Thor's world in thor
ragnarok however he's almost an
ancillary one appearing only in the
opening act and destructive finale
that's not to say he's not important to
the story in Norse mythology the word
Ragnarok points to the apocalyptic
battle between gods that results in a
world destroyed by fire while searcher
is indeed the monster all less Guardians
fear Thor and Loki summon him to invoke
the Ragnarok prophecy this defeats hella
but at a price his attack decimates
Oscar crumbling the city in the sky to
dust the Mandarin ben kingsley's
character in Iron Man 3 wasn't actually
the real Mandor
and the all hail the king one shot short
suggested the bona fide bad guy could
still be out there
waiting to make his move but that fake
Mandarin still gave us the chills at
least until it was revealed that he's
really just an out-of-work actor named
Trevor Slattery who can barely be
trusted with a six-pack of beer much
less a gun still though it loses some
luster by the end the Mandarin presented
in the front half of Iron Man 3 is one
of the scariest baddies in the MCU it
might have been a ruse but it was
effective and you'll never see me coming
red skull there was every chance it
would come off as silly but red skull
easily stands out is one of the most
original and terrifying baddies in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in the First
Avenger he commands his own Hydra
branded Nazi division
complete with tesseract powered weapons
and he has his own version of the Super
Soldier Serum making him caps physical
equal he vanished while trying to
harness the power of the tesseract space
stone but his surprise return as the
guardian of the soul stone an infinity
war only served to remind us how great
he was so many years ago
Casilla Asst he might have been just a
disciple of Dormammu
but cassellius was plenty intimidating
in his own right a highly trained
sorcerer who went rogue left the Ancient
Ones ordered to try to take out the
Masters of the mystic arts nearly
succeeded in Doctor Strange Casillas
manages to destroy two sanctums but the
Ancient Ones forces on the ropes and
shows his prowess with magic and a few
excellent fights against Doctor Strange
luckily a quick-thinking strange managed
to turn the tables of wind today even if
he was technically the b-list baddie and
Doctor Strange he'll always be an
a-lister to us crossbones Brock rumlow
started out as a member of Captain
America's strike team in Winter Soldier
eventually revealing himself as a Hydra
agent when the attempted takeover began
he managed to survive and resurface
during the opening fight in civil war
where he went toe-to-toe with both cap
and black widow before blowing himself
up in the event that ended up driving
the Avengers apart for a villain that's
a pretty good way to go out
Dormammu he's one of the biggest
villains in Marvel Comics and the MCU
actually kept the extremely powerful
ruler of the Dark Dimension relatively
close to his comics counterpart Doctor
Strange his trip to the Dark Dimension
was practically a Steve Ditko panel
brought to life Dormammu is so powerful
that Doctor Strange had no chance of
hurting he had to outsmart him to save
the world he trapped the villain in a
time loop where Dormammu killed him over
and over until he was forced to bargain
for his freedom
it makes for one of the most clever
finales in all of the MCU and lands
Dormammu high on our list of favorites
Alexander Pierce when Marvel signed
Robert Redford for a superhero movie you
knew it'd be an interesting role and his
turn as Alexander Pierce delivered he's
introduced as the well-meaning secretary
of the world Security Council an old
friend of Nick Fury though it's
eventually revealed that Pierce is
actually a Hydra agent leading their
infiltration of shield Pierce shepherded
the program designed to create the
network's Helicarrier system everyone is
fighting over in the Winter Soldier
he also planted bombs in the name tags
of the other security council members
which he uses to brutally murder them
when they challenge his takeover
he stayed evil to the end - uttering
hail Hydra with his dying breath after
Nick Fury put two rounds into his chest
now that's a villain
yeah aldrich killian Iron Man 3 is one
of the most polarizing movies in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe featuring an
epic fake-out that reveals guide
Pierce's aldrich killian is actually the
villain behind a mysterious rash of
bombings and terrorists attacks sweeping
the globe his secret weapon extremity a
versatile technology that first showed
up in the Iron Man comics and has
reimagined here as a way to superheat
one's body and literally regrow limbs
Killians particular skill set makes for
one of the most technically ambitious
fight scenes in the MCU it's sometimes
hard to believe any villain can truly go
toe-to-toe with Tony Stark
but Killian made a heck of a run the
Grandmaster when Thor is suddenly
marooned on the junk planets a car he
comes in contact with the Grand Master
in the comics the Grand Master is just
an immortal dude who loves playing games
of any kind but in the hands of Jeff
Goldblum the Grand Master becomes one of
the weirdest and funniest characters in
the MCU here's hoping we get to see a
lot more of him in the future though
maybe not as much as he wants us to on
any other world I'd be like millions of
years old but here on Shekhar
Iron Monger you have to respect where it
all began and Jeff Bridges Obadiah Stane
aka Iron Monger set the tone for the
villains of the MCU in the first Iron
Man film bridges stain is positively
slimy betraying Tony Stark and actually
setting his entire hero's journey in
action so really we can thanks Dane for
kicking off the entire Marvel Cinematic
Universe when his assassination attempt
on Stark in the desert failed stain
eventually done the massive Iron Monger
suit to try and finish the job himself a
lot has changed since Iron Monger
stocked the skies but his final fight
with Iron Man had a brutal messy feel
that really let you feel the hate stain
head for Stark and it still resonates
even in a world with heavy hitters like
daños prowling around Ultron James
Spader brought absolute terror to the
metal menace that was Ultron with a near
endless supply of robot baddies and a
design that had comics fans geeking out
he exemplifies how technology can be our
greatest scourge though Ultron doesn't
with a width that only Spader can
provide verbally sparring with the best
of them like any great villain Ultron
also has a real motivation for his
dastardly deeds looking at the facts
Ultron's final determination that humans
and superheroes are what make the world
such a dangerous place makes its own
twisted kind of sense helmet Zemo the
most amazing thing about helmets emo and
civil war is he's just an average guy no
plans for world domination just a man
who once revenge for the death of his
family and wise enough to realize the
best way to take out the Avengers is to
set them against one another
yes his plan does require a few big
leaps of movie logic but it was
refreshing to see a villain like Zemo
brought to life in the MCU he's a great
reminder that it doesn't take world
smashing superpowers to give Earth's
Mightiest Heroes a run for their money
ego Peter Quill's search for his father
was a key part of guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 a journey that brought him
face to face with Kurt Russell
ego who's as bad a dad as they come yes
Drex
I got a penis thank you ego is one of
the most powerful villains in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe right up there
alongside daños himself egos essentially
a God who wants to literally become the
universe by supplanting all other life
and Russell sells it so well that you
really understand where egos coming from
even if he's a psychopath who's killed
hundreds of his own children in his
quest for power ego redefined the
concept of daddy issues the vulture in a
universe of world destroying monsters
the vulture is decidedly street-level in
his approach but that's exactly what
makes him work the writers tweaked his
backstory to make Adrian Toomes the
father of Peter Parker's teenage crush
and spider-man homecoming and he takes
the girlfriends angry dad trope to a
whole new level the effects team also
did an amazing job with his armor and
look with the vulture looking positively
terrifying and inhuman when he's
stalking his prey hello we've never seen
Thor face a villain like hella the
goddess of death in any of the other MCU
films much like Loki before her
this is Guardian villain is someone
audiences will immediately love to hate
as soon as Odin passes away hella
appears to the brothers it presents her
plan to take her rightful place on house
guards throne to prove her point she
easily crushes Thor's hammer the truth
is eventually revealed that hella once
acted as Odin's executioner leading the
s Guardian army to victory over all nine
realms this secret history elevates
Pella to epic villain status Erik kill
monger Erik kill monger essentially has
a super heroes origin his father is
killed right in front of him his royal
heritage is denied to him and he uses
those tragedies to motivate a relentless
dedication training himself to the peak
of his abilities before seeking
vengeance that setup is a whole lot
closer to Batman than it is to say
crossbones our Ultron
when you add in the fact that kill
monger specifically wants to address a
continuing history of racism it's hard
not to admit that he makes some pretty
good points
even if he's right though his goal is
dominance rather than leadership which
makes him a true ideological opponent
for T'Challa it's one of the things that
makes their final battle in which
they're in both nearly identical black
panther costumes so good their
reflections of each other both committed
to fight for their ideals without
compromising who they are loki while we
originally said that villains turn to
good guys weren't going to be on the
list we had to make an exception for the
god of mischief
especially since Loki was a baddie for
multiple Marvel movies and caused so
much chaos throughout the MCU Tom
Hiddleston is so good at being bad that
Marvel opted to keep him around long
after his good for supremacy was foiled
at the hands of Earth's Mightiest Heroes
he's still no match for the Hulk but who
is oh wait we know who danos Thanos is
the villain of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe there's been a lot of character
work put into this cinematic version of
Thanos which is especially impressive
considering that most of it is shown to
the audience and infinity war a movie
that's also juggling story arcs for
dozens of other characters at the same
time through it all he's shown to have
the same quality that all the greatest
villains share he thinks he's right he's
the hero of his own story the only one
who can step up and save the universe
from itself and is willing to sacrifice
whatever he needs to in pursuit of that
goal in the comics Thanos has been
referred to as the ultimate nihilist but
the MCU is version is the exact opposite
he believes very much in what he's doing
which makes him even more compelling and
more dangerous